WHAT DO YOU DO?
DO BIG BOYS FOR EDMONDTO
WHISTLE.
WHAT A START.
TALKED ABOUT THE NEUTRAL ZONE IN
THE PREGAME SHOW WITOKEN UP.
HERE COMES CONNOR McDAVID.
MOVING IN  AG UNABLE TO CLEAR.O.
DUNCAN KEITH CLEARS THE PUCK: M
GAME ONE
HE IS STILL CHATTING AND
BA
CHANCES.
LEON DRAISAITL WITH A REALLY
GOOD OPPORTUNITY
THE CREASE.
HERE IS McDAVID BACK OUT FOR>>
BY SMIKE
SMITH.
HE WALKS IN HERE HR TO MacKINNO
IT TAKES A CRAZY BOUNCE D KADRIO
THE AVALANCHE STRIKE FIRST!
NUMBER 14! LIKE IT GET
CHIPPEJUST LETS
A SL
HOW GOOD IS THIS LINE BEEN?
>> Keith: ALL THREE GOALS THISTT
JOSH MANSON WITH A
THE WAY.
E, THINGS
ARE GOING TO OPEN UP A SECONDS.
>> Eddie: IT SEEMS LIKE TWO BLE
ON THE ICE.
>> Kenny: MacKINNON INTO THE
EDMONDTON ZONE MEN ON THE ICE F
OILERS.
MAKAR.
MacKcK
SCORESD NATHAN
Ma